[Music]
when historians talk about the
atrocities of the 20th century
we often think of those that took place
during and between
the two world wars along with the
armenian genocide in modern-day turkey
the rape of nan king in china and
kristallnacht in germany
another horrific ethnic cleansing
campaign occurred on an island
between the atlantic ocean and caribbean
sea
the roots of this conflict go back to
when christopher columbus stumbled onto
the caribbean island
that would come to be named hispaniola
launching a wave
of european colonization the island's
taino natives
were decimated by violence and disease
and the europeans
imported large numbers of enslaved
africans
to toil in profitable sugar plantations
by 1777
the island had become divided between a
french-controlled west
and a spanish-controlled east a mass
slave revolt won haiti its independence
from france in 1804
and it became the world's first black
republic but the new nation
paid dearly shut out of the world
economy and
saddled with debt by its former masters
meanwhile the dominican republic would
declare independence by first
overthrowing haitian rule
of eastern hispaniola and later spanish
and american colonialism
despite the long and collaborative
history shared by these two countries
many dominican elites saw haiti as a
racial threat that
imperiled political and commercial
relations with
white western nations in the years
following world war 1
the united states occupied both parts of
the island
it did so to secure its power in the
western hemisphere
by destroying local opposition and
installing us-friendly governments
the brutal and racist nature of the u.s
occupation
particularly along the remote dominican
haitian border
laid the foundation for bigger
atrocities after its withdrawal
in 1930 liberal dominican president
oracio vasquez
was overthrown by the chief of his army
rafael trujillo
despite being a quarter haitian himself
trujillo saw the presence of a
bicultural haitian and dominican
borderland
as both a threat to his power and an
escape route
for political revolutionaries in a
chilling speech
on october 2nd 1937 he left
no doubt about his intentions for the
region claiming to be protecting
dominican farmers from
theft and incursion trujillo announced
the killing of 300 haitians
along the border and promised that this
so-called
remedy would continue over the next few
weeks
the dominican military acting on
trujillo's orders
murdered thousands of haitian men and
women
and even their dominican-born children
the military targeted black haitians
even though many dominicans themselves
were also dark-skinned some accounts say
that to distinguish the residents of
one country from the other the killers
forced their victims
to say the spanish word for parsley
dominicans pronounce it perejil with a
trilled spanish
r the primary haitian language however
is crayol
which doesn't use a trilled r so if
people struggled to say perahil
they were judged to be haitian and
immediately killed
yet recent scholarship suggests that
tests like this
weren't the sole factor used to
determine who would be murdered
especially because many of the border
residents were bilingual
the dominican government censored any
news of the massacre
while bodies were thrown in ravines
dumped in rivers
or burned to dispose of the evidence
this is why
no one knows exactly how many people
were murdered
though contemporary estimates range from
about four thousand
to fifteen thousand yet the extent of
the carnage
was clear to many observers as the u.s
ambassador to the dominican republic at
the time
noted the entire northwest of the
frontier
on the dahabon side is absolutely devoid
of haitians
those not slain either fled across the
frontier or are still hiding in the bush
the government tried to disclaim
responsibility and blame the killings on
vigilante civilians
but trujillo was condemned
internationally
eventually the dominican government was
forced to pay only 525 thousand dollars
in reparations to haiti but due to
corrupt bureaucracy
barely any of these funds reached
survivors or their families
neither trujillo nor anyone in his
government was ever punished for this
crime against humanity
the legacy of the massacre remains a
source of tension between the two
countries
activists on both sides of the border
have tried to heal the wounds of the
past
but the dominican state has done little
if anything
to officially commemorate the massacre
or its victims
meanwhile the memory of the haitian
massacre remains a chilling reminder
of how power-hungry leaders can
manipulate people into turning against
their lifelong neighbors
[Music]
you